today on our show man news the flash all
new news [ __ ] off mrs. nude man tits on
fat man on Batman
mm-hmm you can't keep this much
chocolate welcome back to fat man batter
I'm Kevin Smith Mike Bernardo it's been
so long I'm so punchy I was overseas
this is all my fault I went away took
that movie money all goes to the
Edinboro Film Festival very
well-received yeah over yeah I'm seeing
like honestly that goddamn tour in the
movie cuz after Sundance I was like that
just wasn't the audience the kids on his
comic book movie audience and stuff like
that the audience is a Sunday has loved
of the critics it's not like this movie
but it was very nice - taking place as I
played in London two screenings at the
at the Prince Charles theatre which was
really sweet to put the kids name up on
the marquee it's very very nice so
anyway that took me out but here we are
we're back we're back we're ready to do
what we do talk about other people who
accomplish things talking about our
betters to make them feel better yes
right how much better they are there and
then reminding us that we could probably
do this [ __ ] - but just apply to
ourselves a little more ain't no
mountain high enough except for that
mountain just easier to talk about
things just are so let's start let's
dive in do it did we talk about I didn't
know cuz I was away battle of the
bastards Game of Thrones see how [ __ ]
whoa ultimate motels that we didn't talk
about that or the last steps we talked
we were leading up to it in Indianapolis
for the wedding who was gonna die and we
didn't know him now we know we're
spoilers that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
Ramsey finally [ __ ] dead and dead in
an awesome one got eight ma'am and a
minimum and the dogs eat his face man
don't see his face and she watched Sansa
was just sitting there man
oh she was enjoying that [ __ ] she became
Sansa became a [ __ ] rock star in the
show remember from first season you're
like oh my god all the people are
killing off take that girl out oh yeah
Joffrey yeah [ __ ] idiots
oh why can't I come with you to King's
Landing Joffrey is gonna be great you
had no idea that is that girl would turn
out metal I bet you he knew that Ariana
would be like Arya would be cool she
wanted to be a sword fighter from the
jump she was I'm ready to cut dicks off
at a young age sauce is just like I'll
cut any dick off [ __ ] little fingers
little dick [ __ ] Ramsay's [ __ ]
little dick Theon's well he does dick
off somebody beat ya well Reid Ramsay
man that's such a satisfy this whole
[ __ ] season finale I mean that was
bad all the bastard up so wonderful yes
[ __ ] like shot like [ __ ] crazy
well this is the film credit you shot
crazy well pretty I'm totally using that
look at the pretty kids the [ __ ]
fight scene was phenomenal they took 25
days to shoot that to shoot the fight
scene just the [ __ ] fight scene your
average TV show gets nine days to shoot
an episode we should dry I directed
flash in eight days today they say they
love 25 days to the shoot for 25 minutes
they had 25 days that's crazy which is
ungodly and but you could see what a
difference it makes like it was
beautiful at all absolutely
but then the season finale was perhaps
one of the most satisfying hours of
anything ever produced I'm not saying
television I'm not saying HBO
I'm not saying things made by human
hands I'm saying the universe in an hour
of making life and [ __ ] pollen and
bees making flowers of [ __ ]
none of that compared to satisfying as
the final Game of Thrones episode was
they tied up so many loose ends took off
so much dead [ __ ] weight who I didn't
even consider dead weight but once they
killed him like I guess you don't need
this
the dragons were flying and [ __ ] like
that [ __ ] Daenerys is finally on the
goddamn boat look that [ __ ] when she
[ __ ] met and they were like you know
talking about the surrender and she's
Lilly you [ __ ] don't understand rain
is just begun oh [ __ ] my dick was so
hard and then where she's and then she
sends him up dude to burn the one
[ __ ] boat and the other two dragons
finally came out like let's do it come
on it looked like the most metal album
cover of all was just the moshu s-- but
so good season finale dude they tied up
all the [ __ ] loose ends and set it in
motion for what they're saying there's
only two seasons left yet they're not
each gonna have ten episodes well you
like eight and eight or ten and six or
in the final stretch let's say fifteen
sixteen uh positions the third act of
this story now that's exciting like do
the George RR Martin's excited - he's
like I want to know where it's going -
seriously I saw some tweet from him
saying uh those pricks know was like Oh
Leanna more month little ten-year-old
Mormon girl it was the [ __ ] most
metal girl on the ship he's like oh you
like the character huh hmm really
yeah like he's gonna kill her because
that's what he does I thought maybe it
was like oh you like that character
she's gonna be here oh the next book
like if I was him I know he wouldn't do
this cuz he's a purist and [ __ ] but I'd
be like what are they saying well [ __ ]
if they liked her guess what she's the
new hero [ __ ] shots no little girl
little girl Queen who's in charge bear
island or John Targaryen who's that
that would be Jon Snow that's right
because now they [ __ ] told us it's
exclusively clear they told us the worst
kept secrets no baby was a baby once
what a baby he was John Snow
apparently the child of a Targaryen is a
Rhaegar Rhaegar and Lyanna it's so dark
Ned's sister yes so Ned's sister was
like don't [ __ ] see I got to write
you guys on the internet I figure this
[ __ ] out therefore I'm for justice on
that one
speaking of let's put a pin on that and
jump to the / speaking of the LA Times
Marga wrote a wonderful article in the
only time so those that don't follow
that closely mark has a [ __ ] day job
legit day job he's the grown-up in the
room where he edits the film section of
calendar yes of the LA time the only
times
so that's [ __ ] huge is look job three
papers that if all the other papers in
this country folded the New York Times
the LA Times the Chicago Tribune I'd
imagine or the Washington Post
it's a four there's probably 80 papers
that are never full [ __ ] one of them
in any event BFG
yes big [ __ ] giant the medal as US
movie that Sabeel burg ever made leave
that big [ __ ] Giants about a huge
[ __ ] big [ __ ] gun it is big was a Big
Friendly Giant guess Big Friendly Giant
the Spielberg movie Spielberg for those
of you who just tuned in is a master
film yes he makes movies he makes
phenomenal 29 feature films to date and
this is a relevant information as Mark
just said 29 feature films correct
because Mark I did did what everybody
does on the Internet yeah have you met
the Internet where we rank things
Spielberg from first to worst I did now
we're showing you that not because marks
[ __ ] proud that he's in print and
[ __ ] but there's a reason mark made a
list of what he feels is Spielberg from
first to worst yes his you know this is
my number one pick and there's my last
28 28 pick yes what do you think 28 is
no jaws number one yes the big
I figure this out and you do you think
he gives a [ __ ] that like I don't think
the world feels this way but I think
there are a lot of us that are like jaws
your best work and that's not to say
like the rest of your work is dog [ __ ]
mr. Spielberg like he's made amazing
films by only they talk about me and my
cradle he [ __ ] peaked with his first
movie in [ __ ] we're still talking about
jaws yeah like and the fact that he was
that good
that quit yes he's [ __ ] banana but
there's something to be said it's not
like you know and ever since jaws has
been coasting clearly the man's a genius
and he's made [ __ ] fantastic films
and stuff but he [ __ ] announced
himself with such thunder that like like
he created a genre of films they get
traded the blockbuster with his first
feature film not crazy good about clerks
yeah until I've thought about this I'm
like oh yeah he's a jerk sorry second
feature film Sugarland Express befores
before that no it's good movie shoot
movies totally [ __ ] in Jaws come on
just jaws is the birth of movie going as
we know it today yeah and you know one
of the greatest [ __ ] monster movies
ever made and [ __ ] the you take
Spielberg out of the equation B movie
yeah Corman could have made this [ __ ]
Spielberg involved just one of the
greatest movies of all time they're
still talking about so Marc put that at
number one yes number two Raiders I buy
that but let's go to you said what's 20
what's 28 what's that what's the last of
the list not counting BFG which we
hadn't seen before to press date always
oh no I don't like it either but it's
not the worst
what where'd you go I went Crystal Skull
oh yeah I caught my reaction on that
music yeah you might you know I like
1941 is a better movie than Christmas
girl it indeed your ear of right though
and I you know that but again that's not
saying it's [ __ ] socks is just on the
Spielberg scale totally like we admit
none of us could make that movie No now
I'll admit I wouldn't want to what
that was but like I don't have the
talent to pull off that movie this is
just saying of all his theorem on the
continuum like there's always got to be
a best and a worst if you're doing that
many [ __ ] movies by process of
elimination yes so there's got to be the
worst tell them what happened next I you
know cuz the internet and starting to
get [ __ ] from the internet have you seen
the movie duel my friend duel the great
Steven Spielberg feature film not a
feature film TV movie TV movie thought
that's the TV movie legendary TV movie
and a precursor to jaws like basically
watch do when you watch jaws you're like
oh I get it yeah [ __ ] jaws is duel
with a shark before but that's
technically and I would I wouldn't have
put that on the list either because
that's TV movie and I'm not saying
that's bad but it says you clearly said
his feature film feature film yeah so
get [ __ ] for that I got [ __ ] for not
living Munich apparently as much as I
should love Munich really there's a
Munich like there's a Munich contingent
that was heretofore never brought to
bear III honestly like I'm not like
[ __ ] Munich I just don't remember
much about yeah like I remember some of
the [ __ ] killing and stuff but just
in general like it doesn't like I don't
like there's a lot of Spielberg movies
on this list where you pull here pull
random time ya war horse is about this
world war one story I was the based on
play yeah that was out like two years
ago uh-huh
alright not later Spielberg yeah alright
hold on I must add another one you
didn't see well I saw it but like I'm
looking for the magical Spielberg oh you
a magic spear not the history of this
land you know well that's history led
like Spielberg is has become our
cinematic history teacher right he likes
to be like hey remember this remember
the Cold War remember these things and
it's great but you know I it's funny
like I realized that when ranking this
thing he has his reputation of being our
reiji's younger filmmaker yeah he almost
never looks forward like he's made two
movies set in the future
give him a single is he gonna sit good
keep on that signal is important ai is
in the future and war the world's I'm
sorry
no [ __ ] the other one Minority Report
those the only two movies where he looks
into the future night where otherwise we
said in the future everything is that
the contemporary or in the past and even
the shara ones we love are in the past
explain like tell me what I'm about to
say yes you're right you know like it's
either contemporary ordered like
Jurassic Park even close encounters even
et although they're about aliens but
they're now because he wants to tell us
stories about now like divorce and
family and and fractured fat you know he
was he was definitely on the divorce
train long before and well like him and
Kramer vs Kramer hmm were the kind of
people to break to the world like there
is such a thing as divorce sometimes
parents get [ __ ] divorced and used it
in all of his movies so not all of them
but a lot of his movies like yeah
especially like children of divorce like
you know an ET it is fundamentally clear
that this is a family that has been sort
of torn a bit by divorce but here's how
we get through it I like to think of it
as the et family is the Brody family
but chief Brody got eaten by a short
that same story with Lorraine Gary
played you know if it could have been
the follow-up to jaws 5 remember the
jaws revenge where she was the big
player Ellen Brody back you gotta back
totally then you could have gone to I'm
just saying missed opportunities right
no but but what let's go to Munich real
quick how much [ __ ] did you did you take
like I mean I submitted piece of [ __ ] is
that not so much it was more like I
really feel like and it's always like
older people who are a bit cine asked so
like I feel like you should revisit
Munich there's a lot to recommend him
but I'll take that over someone man you
[ __ ] face
[ __ ] you actually like this [ __ ]
like I do it's really a juice no where'd
you put it on the list not there Munich
is 20 let's do your list what we got
right so start from the bottom even
though we know the last one yeah I
[ __ ] start from one because we know
it we've spoiled it already number one
is jaws remember what is jaws number two
is Raiders yes
number three Saving Private Ryan Wow
you know this would be an impossible
list for me to do I'm glad you did it
but I loved that movie
like that is an utterly [ __ ]
watchable movie and it's incredibly
well-made and [ __ ] for opening half out
of that movie is some of the most
gripping [ __ ] storytelling ever yeah
told in the history of mankind happens
cameras and [ __ ]
you're not going to put you if it makes
you feel like I never feel like I was on
a battlefield you're [ __ ] I'd [ __ ]
the closest you'll ever get to that it
gave you more than any other movie I've
ever seen like it gave me a distinct
impression of oh my god and he did it
again in Lincoln yeah the opening of
Lincoln is like even more horrifying on
some level than [ __ ] the opening of
Saving Private Ryan goes like
[ __ ] getting their face pushed
in the dirt with a boot and stabbed with
a [ __ ] knife all the fighting is just
filthy and mucky and horrible the story
that I heard was that for some ever I'm
lucky for Private Ryan
they didn't really have a script for
that sequence because Spielberg wanted
it to feel random he wanted it to feel
like anything could happen and anything
did happen so like the dude whose guts
are coming out like we don't know where
that's gonna go the sequence
good great idea let's do it now so it
felt a series of vignettes but he's like
I'll smash it yeah so it would feel as
if you got off of that boat and you're
just thrown into war and everything he's
just coming out you were once and
nothing makes any sense it absolutely
[ __ ] plays like that man like you
were disoriented yeah like somebody
coming off that boat but can you imagine
on that landing once again first [ __ ]
four dudes get taken out and you're like
yeah which is like we're gonna improvise
this massive sequence with hundreds and
millions of dollars on the line making
up as we go
I mean if you're gonna trust anybody
we [ __ ] saved your ass with jaws I'm
sure all right so he also created a
problem with Java that's the beauty of
jaws is he created a problem let's make
a movie on the water and there was a
clock and then had to solve the problem
and created a cinematic masterpiece the
shack don't work this tale is long and
still you were like jaws is number one
that says something that movie
yeah ISM is amazing if you haven't
watched jaws lately the [ __ ] is your
breath and if you can ever see it on the
big screen with a crowd is so it's
funnier if I ever gave it credit for
yeah like it's got so much hard it's got
so much humor and it [ __ ] moves and
the characters all pop and then when it
slows down and slows down for a reason
it slows down to hear the Indianapolis
story it slows down to here you know
just to look at quints like on the edge
of that thing just like looking nothing
but this is my thing I've said about
that movie forever cuz you know I'm
always like I love jaws influential and
like why you never made a movie like
just well I am gonna make moose jaws but
still my favorite part of Jaws I think
one of the most profoundly impactful
parts of Jaws everybody talks about
Indianapolis speech least cinematic part
of the movie yeah literally just hanging
a camera on a guy was talking that's the
least cinematic thing you could do in a
movie is put a camera I'm of a Kevin
Smith could've shot that see that's how
[ __ ] easy that scene is to shoot and
surrounded by that scene is a bunch of
movie with [ __ ] rubber sharks and
[ __ ] people gettin eaten and cool
[ __ ] and me with POV cameras in that
music and [ __ ] but like so many people I
think I would say everybody remembers
that [ __ ] speech and they didn't cut
to flashbacks of like here's the sharks
biting people and [ __ ] it's literally
just Robert Shaw telling story and
reaction shots from like Richard
Dreyfuss and and Roy Scheider mmm that's
some epic storytelling dude yeah like in
the middle of that special-effects
extravaganza where you've created the
summer blockbuster and everybody's
sitting around going oh my god
you stop and do the oldest thing in the
book like listen this guy tells story
and everybody looks at somebody talking
powerful yeah all right let's do the rat
list so number three private ryan'
number four et number five Schindler's
List
although shouldn't least I probably
would have moved that higher notch I
would have done that as number two jaws
and then Schindler's pardon me yeah
Schindler's this is an amazing [ __ ]
film anybody's I mean and even for
bringing a five it's still an amazing
movie yeah it just did for me it's
for the fact that Spielberg connect he'd
get overly sentimental at times and
overly manipulative at times and the
tail end of Schindler gets that way for
me with the putting the rocks on the
green stuff it's like it's in case you
didn't cry and all this atrocity like
and honestly that's a dude
going underlining the Oscar and he did
you know he earned it at that point that
is a grim [ __ ] tale like it there's
like you know there's light at the end
of the tunnel but even in the [ __ ]
saving there's the speech about like
this pin could have saved so many more
lives like it is relentlessly like the
Holocaust relentlessly [ __ ] bleak and
there's this one shining light of this
man who save these people's life that
color sequence with the rocks on the
grave dude that's you know that's like
ah like it worked out for some people
they've got you know these the who they
were they survivors and that some of
their families stuff like I never
faulted him for that but I remember like
Harvey was mad about that yes I forget
what was Miramax had something against
Schindler's List that year mmm and you
know he was just like we're gonna lose
cuz the rock scene was like life is
beautiful or something like no it was
not even close that was later on but I
mean it would be something like crying
game or what else piano maybe around
that dad feels like maybe but all right
so Schindler's lesson remember what's by
five Close Encounters is six Jurassic
Park is seven or the world is eight well
it's just like could you imagine being
able to rattle off these titles as yours
like if I were to do this list I'm like
these are movies I've seen and also
again like Schindler's List in Jurassic
Park the same year I know yeah I
remember the anterior I do he looked
this he left the you know he always
leaves while they're shooting the last
scene because on jaws they were gonna
throw him in the water or so he's like
I'm not doing that
and he left while they were still
shooting the last scene so he's done
that apparently traditionally all the
way through so I guess he left like
Jurassic Park
[ __ ] Schindler's land I think he was
cut
Jurassic while on set like look the
first avid ever was brought to his
trailer on on Schindler's List we could
come back to digital yeah did you
imagine like talk about using two
different parts of your brain and heart
to tell stories like you know [ __ ]
Jurassic Park is thrilling in you know
dinosaurs eating the [ __ ] out of cars
and [ __ ] and Schindler's List is
thrilling because it's just insanely
emotional storytelling like you and you
always knew that dude was good at family
like you know for the jaws scene alone
with the head and said this is one of
the greatest moments in history and
stuff so seeing him get into Schindler's
List and he also has personal ties and
stuff yeah that's my movie stick yeah so
we're the world's Lincoln is 9 Last
Crusade
it's nine nine unless you liked it that
much I did like it like it's it's
restrained in a way that you don't see
Spielberg be that very much like of all
of the white guys solve problems that
black people have movies he makes that
is the best of them so yeah
10 is Last Crusade 11 is catch me if you
can it's so much fun as a really great
floom aah
12 is Minority Report two mice fell on a
bowl of cream it's fun like that bit
weed these other cameras charming his
[ __ ] eye movie is the least
insufferable he's ever been really can
any member at one point he's like
passing himself off as Barry Allen he
has flash comics it's such a good mood
12 is Minority Report 13 is a good movie
- 13 is bridge of spies 14 yeah it's
like a really well-made watch like all
it's doing the telling time but it's
selling time in a really just totally
efficient totally synchronized what in
the dude is good damn this is good Tom
Hanks does what Tom Hanks does he's not
special
it's just good
14 is lost world Jurassic Park 15
Sugarland Express 16 a i-17 Adventures
of where'd you put lost world 14 how to
put that in the bottom five yeah for me
I remember watching it before Jurassic
world came out and I was like I like
this I like the first one a lot more
than this mmm not in some bad movie by
any stretch imagine it's the glass scene
your glass there's this breaking as cool
[ __ ] but yeah there are some sequences
that are great but it's just like
perfunctory 17 is adventures of tintin
18 Wow it's fun it's fun like it's to
give it a watch because it does the
things that Spielberg has always wanted
to do but couldn't because of like
gravity and physics but now it's
animated so we can do whatever he wants
and there's a great [ __ ] like four
minutes chase scene uncut with Tintin
just racing off for this damn that's
going to like exploding and trucks are
chasing and missiles and explosions and
he's on a motorcycle a motorcycle falls
apart ISM it's just like you [ __ ]
sold the ticket dude there's a blotch of
some fun stuff in there okay
Temple of Doom 18 okay 19 is and part of
the Sun 20 munich 21 color purple 22
warhorse goes to purple i mean i guess
is that that's not considered a like i
figured thank you so much like i'd like
color purple I like that movie love you
know it's probably [ __ ] emotional top
15 very emotional it was like till you
do right by me
everything you do gonna fail oh it's
just like he's he's plucking every heart
string he possibly can about a woman
who's [ __ ] freedom from the tyranny
of a shitty husband and a [ __ ] shitty
life across the board is making pants
like remember at the end of the day she
makes pants and it was a guy good
[ __ ] oh my god did the ending and I
moved in but there that's gonna make me
cry just like she's in the store and all
the sudden like finally after all that
time she sees her sister and they do
this yes and bank with like her children
like the grand where'd you put this
movie that's number 21 you piece of [ __ ]
haier we almost just cried together this
is what my email looks how dare you must
be a racist self-loathing black I can't
wait to see your face what oh my bad
excuse me oh here that would go higher
for me just even in fact I'm gonna go
home tonight and watch a color purple
yeah I almost cried dude thinking about
that last scene I forgot about that
I remember watching that in the theater
and [ __ ] ball and I was a teenager
nice explain it to my teenage friends
they're like oh all right Lin warhorses
22 I didn't see this movie and yeah man
and still 22 to 23 is hook its way for
is the terminal remember the terminal
Tom Hanks stuck in an airport yeah for a
movie that's not in that just by process
of elimination not like this movie just
lies it's just it doesn't have a reason
to exist beyond they wanted to make a
movie where they didn't have to travel
so they built a set in Palo Alto they
can drive - it's like they saw clerks no
I can't one set 25 as always I love
always 26 his dutiful movie but you're
probably right to put it like 25 26 is
Amistad 27 1941 and 28 kingdom of the
Crystal Skull so 1941 is almost the back
end of the list
yeah even years later really did Yuri
watch it yeah and it's just like just
because Spielberg is a fun filmmaker
does not make him a funny filmmaker and
John Belushi
it's jumble it but it's just he doesn't
as in tax Hollywood
I remember the opening scene to was the
riff on Jos uh like Christopher Lee that
is you needed you needed like Zucker
Abraham's sucker to make that make that
work and and what that movie looked big
and expensive it really did and even for
whatever the [ __ ] that was like nineteen
eighty yeah maybe we spent forty million
dollars on this Spielberg's dance scene
directors they say every director has a
dance scene in them it's just part of
your DNA I did one on clerks too and I'm
not even a [ __ ] director bunch
stretch the imagination but apparently
it's true every filming like the Coen
brothers recently have been like yep it
was a cool numbers and [ __ ] dance up a
storm
that's just look at that I did what the
internet does I made a list and go see
BFG did you see it I did not see it and
nobody else did by the way into our box
office report ahead box I was roundup
alright so of the forty weekend these
are estimates still record a meaning for
the July weekend Sunday so who knows
what happens on right I mean Monday
could be [ __ ] nuts could be
Independence Day literally ships could
come down blow up movie in the interests
and tossed office is over and these
numbers are inaccurate or there'll be
the last numbers anybody ever saw
finding dory what is number one finding
dory of course you've seen this I have
seen I still have not I want to and I'd
like to didn't love it you know like
it's missing the metaphor that was so
strong in the first movie which was you
know the father who has to learn to let
his son go and by letting him go is how
he's gonna bring him back and then the
son who has to learn that his father's
not overwhelmingly awful just for being
a dad and that being alone it's not the
worst thing in the world Jesus Christ
man like that what Nemo's about that's
kind of what Nemo's about that's what
you want this dude around explain [ __ ]
to you I just liked it because there's a
Gaza fish story yeah and it's the
wonderful it is a beautiful [ __ ]
waiter but it's no dory doesn't quite
have that I mean Dory has a nice
metaphor in there which is it's
basically the kid who gets lost in a
mall who feels like it's been that kid's
fault the whole time like it's Dory who
was like sort of short-term amnesia
wanders away from her parents and can
never find them again and so she's been
holding on to this blame the one thing
she can't remember is how bad she feels
that her parents been looking for her
for as long as she thinks they've been
looking for her and so when finding Dory
actually happens it's in the title just
like finding Nemo you've gotta find Nemo
they find Dory like it's this great
heartbroken moment of her saying I'm
sorry for being lost
which just breaks your heart into his
kid has been just holding on to this
agony for however long fish live years
maybe decades I don't know weeks clear
this all happened thirty seconds after
Nemo ended because fish lived lives
likewise done but you know it's for all
I was about talking tears it is Duchess
saw opening scene where she was a little
baby fish yeah the cue teaching with the
cues voice and look and then teaching
her to say like I have suffer from short
and make sure they're like acting out of
school scenario right I'm a stranger's
seeing but it's not looking for Nemo
don't go looking for the sort of sage
wisdom of Nemo and just go look of
adoring a good pretty much and I took my
kid I took my daughter and she was and
if case you don't realize the story of
my daughter which we talked about in
Indianapolis is my daughter's autistic
and finding Nemo is the one movie she
will watch from beginning to end but and
she's 13 and so I've seen Finding Nemo
now it's 432 times maybe and it holds up
like a scholar spend a lot of my life
I've got a PhD in Nemo so I took her to
see it and she was like mildly diverted
for a while and then like bored because
it's a part of the movie that's all
boring and then when it gets colorful
and pop again she just started to sing
let just keep swimming just keep
swimming I don't know if this will be
for her what Nemo is for her but she
won't watch it as much
yeah god I hope not because utopia she
watched Autopia yeah she didn't like she
learn Cantonese utopia as much as the
boy did but
holy [ __ ] I had to I shoot if I didn't
have to but I was on planes Lots so I
was like oh I'll [ __ ] watch utopia
what an amazing [ __ ] flick yeah so
beautiful and jason bateman and was room
Jennifer Goodwin hmm they deserve Awards
for their performances I mean the
animators of course deserve your words
for creating the look and everything
like that but their performances are so
beautiful
like Jason Bateman they should give him
all the awards this year he was I think
my favorite person in the movie this
year might be Jason Bateman as that
[ __ ] Fox yeah he was so [ __ ]
charming so touching like it has one of
the best like a broken-hearted apology
scenes I've ever seen a movie where
she's like and you could hey oh my god
it's such a good flick but it also just
works as a buddy cop movie yeah like
it's well plotted and it also is a
really kind of trenchant like racial
allegory that's the [ __ ] way that's
the thing that blows your hair back
where you're watching the movie gone
like oh they're they're talking yeah
holy [ __ ] and all the best movies don't
[ __ ] like bang you over the head I
saw somebody online was like liberal
[ __ ] [ __ ] I didn't feel that at
all I didn't feel preached to and then
about when I finally figured out what
was going on I was like holy [ __ ] this
is brilliant because who's [ __ ]
watching this bunch of kids who needs
this bunch of [ __ ] kids believe is an
adult message is beautiful and clear and
[ __ ] oh it was just so well [ __ ]
executed apparently the same people who
did frozen big hero 6 and wreck-it Ralph
yes which is getting a sequel and
wreck-it Ralph they've just announced is
getting a sequel so everybody coming
back and they said last one was in the
world of video games this one takes
place I think in the real world issue in
the Internet they said that takes place
or they're out of the game
there's got to be enough internet games
to be liked but also like those
characters on say tumblr or Instagram or
social media like there's plenty of
awful paths to walk down there's a
writer right there thinking about you
very good at CS adore he was number one
cat fifty three point four million Kara
mystic Tarzan was number two you see
Tarzan I did see Tarzan what you think
did not love Tarzan it seems to have the
critics didn't like it but then there
did better this weekend at the box
office then they thought oh yeah like it
was too because it was like a hundred
and seventy five yeah it was forecasted
for like 30 to 33 million and it made
forty three point one which is still
like not phenomenal for a movie that
cost one hundred eighty five million
being released over Independence Day
weekend but better than like an abject
flop it's just I mean what you hear you
put up a tweet where I was like wow I'd
[ __ ] watch that Tarzan movie like
that and I like this guy Alexander
Skarsgard and I like Margot Robbie the
whole cast nothing wrong with it and
Craig Brewer who did rock Snake Moan
hustling flow
he wrote the draft and scripted co-wrote
his names on it and was the David Yates
is yeah I did a less fortunate like yeah
[ __ ] for really enjoyable Harry Potter
movies so he's got a great pedigree yeah
the product the end of the day it's like
like there's there's about are so who
cares about Tarzan and and at its core
Tarzan is a problematic story to try to
tell in a 21st century milieu which is
so much about colonization and so much
about you know oppression and so much
about sort of subjugation and it's you
know here's Africa and the black people
in Africa or like window dressing in the
background or their dancing or singing
or their the savages who are trying to
stop the two white people from falling
in love and it's like we're in Africa
right could imagine Book of Mormon than
I am
like I should sing you know and like
Disney had made an animated Tarzan yes
which actually has no black people in it
either
Tarzan movie in Africa with no black
people but the fairmark it had Phil
Collins you're gonna take something out
replace it with something amazing
he won an Oscar he totally Dilbert ray
and Matt for blame Canada god damnit one
more reason I like Phil yeah another
reason I Tarzi alright so this version
of it is it like hey this is as good as
I can [ __ ] get or is it like why did
they do this for me it's about could you
save it I like mean I would have saved
it by making Jane an African that's so
[ __ ] smart how come nobody's ever
done that well Holly cuz tell him why
cuz but they'll my makes sense so
because I mean if you've got this
character who's raised in the jungle and
you know why would he in the odds of
people you would encounter in Africa
find the one other white person to then
fall in love with so if his way into the
world would be the people on the edge of
the jungle it should be some African
tribes woman we just falls in love with
and she gets to be the reason why he
falls in love with Africa and she gets
to be the reason why he then goes back
to Africa instead of weird so those
raised babes yes like you know my heart
is here and [ __ ] this is where my love
is and stuff like that yeah that's at
least a like hey that's an update that
makes it's a thing that's a little bit
new yeah and at least it gives me a
reason to want to make a Tarzan movie or
I want to see a Tarzan movie never mind
that you would probably if you're gonna
make like the real Tarzan movie he's
just [ __ ] monkeys the whole time he
is just doing nothing but having sex
with Apes because he absolutely would
they would have my money
I'm not lying right now if somebody was
just like seriously we did it it's
broken up like here you go these guys
just ball deep and gorillas feel like
because it's real we talked to David
Attenborough and he said he's
[ __ ] would absolutely be having
sex was there
and it's a case of like everybody's
doing their job well but it's just like
who gives a [ __ ] yeah ultimately gives a
[ __ ] and I've seen people online like
y'all who's fun is Ripper on adventures
that kind of you know throw that pop I
give a [ __ ] me
they give [ __ ] me Tarzan but I'll watch
the movie I just I don't know if it's
gonna make me go to the future like
let's be honest it's not gonna make me
go to the movie theater I'll totally
watch it you'll see it on a plane and
you'll be like you know what I've seen
worse things totally I mean while David
Yates will never see yo Gosar's never
had that moment on a plane or anything
like that until you king of comedy him
all right let's [ __ ] blow deuce yeah
yeah we got we got news we'll do that
next episode a bunch of news to tell you
moves it up cool [ __ ] man but that
[ __ ] a Spielberg article now see we
had a good time that's a good time right
there good time all right day I'm
guaranteeing a bunch of people watching
the show like I'm totally watching
[ __ ] the poor horse watch [ __ ]
catch me if you can do that what catch
me yeah in color purple even though I
ran to I ranked it yeah number one
because like number one holy [ __ ] I know
it's a movie I forgot and things making
me cry and watch that movie tonight
but when I'm watching that you watch you
can watch color purple as well but you
need to watch catch me if you can it is
[ __ ] delightful it's great and like
young Amy Adams yes how embraces
everybody in the [ __ ] flag man
Jennifer Garner I'm Jennifer Garner's
well I mean something she's old like
Jennifer Garner from a couple years ago
movies that gotta be ten years old yeah
yeah he's little when I say like it I
can look it up if you'd like me to do it
I heard information Aaron's in the LA
Times in the LA Times hold on I got it
an art loss to children today how to
open a new did people watching this but
bit what is that not what you start a
fire with oh hello how are you
2002 two kids 2002 that's yeah coming up
on 15 years old that movie oh my god
yeah you know it was 30 years old
yesterday Big Trouble in Little China
really yeah Wow yes
there was a movie that had quite like
every movie I've ever made was not
embraced at the box of milk but
certainly found its audience afterwards
mouths water just finds its level man
you know [ __ ] him that was not a movie
for everybody until it was at home yes
then it was for everybody totally you
know I I'm maybe people on treated like
religion but I'll give a [ __ ] who you
are you've watched that movie at one
point this is [ __ ] crazy what's going
on here I don't know but I kind of like
it
that's a funny movie yeah Wow thirty
years old black Hill [ __ ] old as in
the big dangly floppy wrinkly old den I
feel young is when the dick was new
there it is come back next week man
we're going to talk about next week next
episode yeah they're like two days from
now we'll talk about some [ __ ] news
right using it news in it there it is
man so that's it for this week for fat
man I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith and I'm
mark come back next week same bat-time
same bat-channel SModcast comm
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
a man's meat Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder